e quindi cominciamo da lontano dal 2.245
l'enterprise chi non la ricorda
spero anche i più giovani dove una cosa
veramente straordinaria e che ci colpiva
da bambini e da grandi era il
teletrasporto e quando ho cominciato ad
avvicinarmi alla stampa 3d
caso vuole che in quegli anni nel 2014
in particolare ha cominciato a
interessarmi la stazione orbitante
quella di prima
era un falso della letteratura
meravigliosa cinematografica
questo è un vero questa è la stazione
orbitante internazionale su quella
stazione orbitante
non tutti lo sanno e ve lo dico io c'è
una stampante 3d e su quella stessa in
orbitante nel 2014 dell'epoca nostra è
successa una cosa straordinaria che
samantha cristoforetti e il suo
equipaggio e bacio il marker
raccomandante hanno chiesto alla base
una cosa perché avevano bisogno di un
oggetto avevano bisogno di un cricchetto
di una chiave hanno mandato questo
messaggio appunto e dalla nasa gli hanno
mandato questo e non l'hanno mandato
soltanto a loro l'hanno mandato
postandolo sul sito di www.nasa.gov dove
tutti potete trovarlo il file cosiddetto
stl che consente di stampare questo e
noi è un po di milioni di altre persone
abbiamo cominciato a stamparlo perché
ma intanto perché è bello è bello sapere
che hai un oggetto che funziona è
stampato per i tecnici in un pezzo solo
non c'è assemblaggio qua dentro c'è una
signora frizione che per spiegare magari
a qualcuno come funzionano funzione
vederla mentre cresce dentro la
stampante ha un significato e e noi
insieme ad alcuni milioni di altri ce lo
siamo stampato e adesso ce l'ho qui e mi
chiedo cos'è straordinario che cos'è
quotidiano
comincia a chiedermelo ora
io posso stampar melo tutti i giorni se
voglio sperimentare la potenza di questo
concetto però certo è stata la prima
volta che è stata come dire realizzata
una stampa 3d e on demand nello spazio
la cosa più vicina al teletrasporto che
io possa proporvi oggi
eccolo qua ed eccolo qua soprattutto poi
a questo punto ho pensato di spostare la
vostra attenzione sul titolo appunto del
mio intervento che fare o non fare non
esiste provare ricorderete anche questa
è una citazione piuttosto colta il
maestro yoda che spero ci perdonerà per
questo uso un po ingegneristico che ora
cominciamo a fare e ci concentriamo su
fare allora andiamo a vedere cosa dice
il vocabolario treccani
quando si parla di fare dice che fare ha
tanti significati ma ce n'è uno quello
lì lì davanti che mi piace perché ha a
che fare con il costruire il fabbricare
il m insieme pensate alla treccani
addirittura per dare il senso di quel
fare dice cita dante colui lo cui saver
tutto trascende fece i cieli ma è che se
gli è inventati li ha fatti pure lui e
lo stesso dell'inglese l'inglese ha un
vantaggio noi fare ne abbiamo uno solo
loro hanno il meraviglioso verbo make
che nell'inglese quindi noi abbiamo
trovato make or make no perché il meic
non il duo che attiene al produrre ed è
quel make che a me interessa sottoporvi
perché vedete io credo in questi sono
vecchia appunto è 35 anni che sto qua e
ne ho viste un po di tutti colori quando
io ero piccola non c'era che due canali
il terzo è arrivato dopo è il telefono
stava alla parete non in tasca e io
allora sono cresciuta in un contesto
dove il fare aveva un profondo
significato fatto ingegneria perché
volevo fare le cose non posso negare che
negli ultimi 15 20 un certo distacco dal
fare nel senso di costruire
a causa della meravigliosa potenza del
usare strumenti che sono potentissimi
che ci fanno connettere che ora ci
guardano in streaming che meraviglia
però se gli apriamo uno di quelli dentro
non sappiamo cosa fare allora io dico
facciamo cose nel senso di make e
cerchiamo di farle in un contesto che
sia di ricerca quindi io cinque anni fa
ho iniziato a dirottare dallo studio
solo delle molecole meravigliose e
polimeri lo studio la plastica a
qualcosa che avesse un'implicazione più
immediata e ci sono tre date che vi
propongo sempre in questo passaggio
temporale che è partito dal futuro
ora torna al passato in bianco e nero le
foto del passato volutamente in quel
laboratorio professor nata conduceva i
suoi studi di chimica analitica e con i
suoi collaboratori prese il premio nobel
per la scoperta del polipropilene
isotattico unico premio nobel per la
chimica di questo paese poi invece nel
1986 meno famoso per i più già cal
questo signore abbia tentato allora era
più giovane ma sempre un po serioso
brevetta la prima stampante 3d non come
quella che ora vedete nelle case un po
diversa ma fa il primo brevetto nell 86
e fa anche un sacco di soldi beato lui
perché ha avuto questa idea
straordinaria di far fare le cose in
modo rapido prodotti pub il eccetera con
stampanti le sue in genere molto costose
per metà tissimo tutto nel 2011 questo
simpatico signore sulla sinistra che si
chiama adam boyer si inventano taci
aveva cominciato a lavorare già prima
nel 2004 circa questo progetto che si
chiama reprap rapproto vuol dire a
replicare rapidamente e quella foto
indica che lui mette a fuoco un concetto
fare macchine a basso costo che siano
genitori di altre macchine a fini quindi
la macchina figlia si stampa con la
macchina
mamma femminile e loro diffondono questo
sapere perché il 2011 perché sono
passati 25 anni dall 86 e nell 86 più 25
scadono i brevetti
quindi questo momento per chi lavora con
la stampa 3d è altrettanto epocale
e allora io decido vengo a contatto
grazie ai miei allievi di design
devo dirlo molto visionari vengo a
contatto con questa cosa del potere ci
provo
almeno nero quotidiano o nello
straordinario vediamo introdurre
stampanti 3d a basso costo
la più costosa il nostro laboratorio
tranne una che particolarissima la più
costosa il nostro laboratorio costa
4.000 euro del grande cose grosse e
quindi produrre strumenti a basso costo
facilmente condivisibili e
intrinsecamente inclusivi cioè ho
pensato che mi pareva interessante fare
cose non per qualcuno soltanto come la
scienza di base fa e dio la benedica
ma c'era un altro binario forse per fare
cose con qualcuno includere persone
normalmente non dedita alla ricerca in
questo percorso
ecco che metto a fuoco una cosa che poi
più tardi tipicamente paio di mesi fa
sento chiamare come io volevo chiamarla
la frugal reserch non me la sono
inventata io
negli stati uniti sta prendendo piede e
proprio assorbire sta facendo cose
meravigliose in cui lui dice siccome i
soldi qua non ce n'era che a loro ce li
hanno ma noi meno quindi per noi è più
vero
non possiamo tutti permetterci macchine
da 500mila euro per fare sognare il
mondo
qualcuno ce le ha ed è bene che con
responsabilità ed etica lavori bene per
diffondere quello che sa poi però
vengono fuori macchine e non solo le
stampanti 3d
i tagli laser addirittura strumenti di
caratterizzazioni materiali che costano
che riusciamo a far costare un po meno
con un concetto di frugalità che è fare
tanto e bene con poco
ed ecco che arriva il più lab i
lavandini sono gli stessi perché il
laboratorio dove io ho l'onore di
lavorare coi miei ragazzi è lo stesso di
quello di giulio nata che faceva le
analisi chimiche e mi trema sempre la
voce quando lo dico non riesco mai a
dirlo tutto filato i lavandini non sono
più apribili per questioni di sicurezza
i balconi sono gli stessi dovremo
metterli a posto per questioni di
sicurezza
e sarà un giorno faticoso comunque lì
abbiamo cominciato con le stampanti e
abbiamo cominciato a connettere persone
perché c'è un fascino c'è un aspetto
ludico
vi ricordate la prima volta che avete
visto una stampante del 3d
spero di sì perché un bel momento tu
vedi le cose che si fanno
il magico e come il teletrasporto e
allora abbiamo cominciato a fare cose
e qui c'è il mio preferito che è mio
nipote matteo che è secondo me la
fortuna spero che la consideri tale in
realtà tre anni fa aveva 10 anni di
vedere una stampante 3d come quella e io
gli chiesi matteo che cosa vuoi fare
ti porto a vedere una stampante 3d e lui
mi disse voglio fare questo voi non lo
vedete si vede un po meglio
nell'immagine di destra e un cubetto di
leggo da uno il suddetto scusa matteo ma
perchè non fai barca a vela
tanta roba no perché poi da uno è per
forza perché i pezzi da uno sono
pregiati sono preziosi perché andrea
meli perde sempre e quando mi servono
non ce li ho lui nega di aver detto
questa frase così oggi più o meno la
detta così e io l'ho fatta mia ed è il
mio slogan che non riesco a cambiare
insieme un altro paio che verranno dopo
la stampa 3d quando mi dicono ma la
professoressa poi alla fine che servirà
la stampa 3d stai sereno intanto la
stampa 3d serve a fare quel che serve
quando serve un concetto raffinatissimo
di questo bimbetto di 10 anni
cambiare il punto di vista a fare ordine
intanto il mondo veniva un po invaso
negli anni successivi da nanetti vasetti
tutti a fare cose la stampa 3d e va bene
per un po va bene e poi bisogna anche
cominciare a fare ordine
e allora abbiamo cominciato a
nazionalizzare questa cosa perché uno
dovrebbe stampare in 3d per esempio per
copiare per esempio per copiare e allora
ci siamo messi a copiare quotidiano
pezzi di milano li vedete la skyline
questo è il castello sforzesco non ha
una risoluzione assoluta da architetto
però una risoluzione quotidiana bella è
che ci ha consentito di avere un
pretesto perché questo lo vide a una
mostra un non vedente il direttore
dell'istituto dei ciechi che mi propose
di portarlo all istituto per far vedere
con le mani milano a chi non vede e
questa è un'altra
come dire pietra miliare della nostra
storia per cui è stato facile entrare in
contatto con persone che con il fare
devono ragionare diversamente che da noi
e così abbiamo cominciato a esplorare il
personalizzare questo è un pezzo di
pirandello che non riesco a non mettere
gli altri li ho tolti per mancanza di
tempo la fantasia abbellisce gli oggetti
cingendogli e quasi irraggiando li
d'immagine care nell'oggetto amiamo quel
che vi mettiamo di noi e tantissima roba
questo cambia il paradigma dell'usa e
getta tutti mi dicono ma non so stampa
in 3d e poi lo butta dipende da cosa c'è
dentro
se lo stampa perché lo vuole perché gli
serve quando serve non lo butterà e
imparerà a ripararlo soprattutto se
piccolo e quindi abbiamo introdotto
questo meraviglioso concetto del
personalizzare non per qualcuno ma con
tutti e allora abbiamo cominciato a
lavorare con persone che hanno l'artrite
e hanno difficoltà aprire le
bottigliette e come loro non da noi che
chissà cosa avremmo tirato fuori
abbiamo iniziato con questo
e poi abbiamo continuato con altre forme
eccola lì per risolvere con loro un
altro problema che voi se non avete
qualcuno ti all'artrite che gli
impedisce di opporre il pollice non ci
avete mica pensato a quanto è difficile
abbassare una cerniera se non puoi
opporre il pollice ti cambia la vita
anche questo perché le ragazze è una
malattia di genere purtroppo quattro su
cinque sono donne avevano già pensato
ferretti legnetti ok sappiamo lo con un
per meno e sono impazzite hanno
cominciato a fare tutti i colori tutte
le formule abbiamo una collezione ognuno
faceva il suo lo pensava se erano brava
a disegnare se lo disegnano da loro e se
no ci sono i designer che sono
straordinarie perché sanno anche
metterci al servizio a volte e quindi
arriviamo a un altro esperimento che
c'entra col quotidiano e quello
straordinario c'entra con la
condivisione di questo meraviglioso
mondo negli stati uniti c'è un ragazzo
fantastico che si chiama andrea
sebastian lui un grande lavorare alla
fondazione google è quello che fa gli
arti a basso costo andatelo a vedere
andreas e lui aveva pensato di stampare
a dei tutori ombretta volare i suoi da
mettere il polso per fare delle cose
piani poi noi con lui ci siamo accorti
che il polimero di cui è fatto questo
oggetto a una meravigliosa transizione
vetrosa quasi lo ha detto oggi è fatto
bene che ci consente di ammonirlo termo
formarlo sulla braccio alla persona
quindi questo non è una polsiera
qualsiasi e la mia e ieri sera con
davide me la sono messa a misura
ecco è dunque fare insieme fare insieme
sono gli unici due nomi che è lecito e
solo laura e poi ci sarà giulia laura
l'abbiamo incontrata al workshop
all'istituto dei ciechi perché lavora
dalla nascita una malattia che peggiora
per cui adesso a uno stato di pove densa
molto spinto e gli ho detto laura ma tu
cosa vorresti fare coste stampanti le è
venuta subito si entusiasma ta
e la prima cosa che ci ha detto ma io
studio la musica si lavora studia
pianoforte batteria tira di scherma fa
cose così è detto io lo spartito in
braille è pesantissimo fatemeh n'è uno
dal nero e magari dalle file midi e così
queste fano che ci ha fatto la laurea
sopra al design ed engineering abbiamo
stampato il primo spartito da file midi
su supporto flessibile col quale
speriamo di andare avanti a come dire
diffondere questo sapere ma poi laura
che hanno una straordinaria sensibilità
ha cominciato a frequentare il
laboratorio ed è venuta a fare
l'alternanza scuola lavoro da noi per
cui laura ha lavorato coi ragazzi qui
c'è valerio che le insegna a cambiare il
filo mi avvicinano proprio lì importanti
una stampante 3d cosa che lei ha fatto e
con lui e con gli altri
lei ha deciso di progettare modellando
con le mani e pongo dall'ego
quell'oggetto sulla destra che la sua
libreria che risolve un po di problemi
di spazio a me ea lei che siamo tanto
disordinate qua sotto c'è un video venne
a trovare laura durante durante il suo
percorso
vincenzo anche vincenzo non ci vede e
loro due hanno lavorato per un
pomeriggio insieme e quello che vedete è
laura che insegna il cambio filo a
vincenzo e quotidiano o straordinario
io non lo so più per me è straordinario
però a noi capita tutti i giorni e poi
da cosa nasce cosa
recitazione e laura dice ma guarda che
c'è un problema se io voglio fare con i
miei amici
vincenzo che fa l'informatico anche di
più dei grafici dei grafici loro ormai
con il voiceover leggono scrivono anche
superando il brive ma i grafici sono un
problema come la fai a vedere una curva
per esempio y uguale a hicks marbella
retta che passa per l'origine la scrivi
l'equazione ma come la vedi lì ancora
oggi molti hanno dei punzoni dove degli
operatori tracciano con un punzone
appunto
il grafico a mano e invece con christian
laura si è messa a lavorare e christian
si lavorerà la settimana prossima per
fare la prima stampante 3d per grafici
tattili quindi lì dentro c'è un punzone
che preleva un file dove c'è quella
retta e fa quello sulla destra si vede
pensavo che noi vedenti non avremmo
avuto modo di vederlo però quello che è
più bello di tutti e questo perché
questo potreste vederlo con gli occhi
chiusi e questo ritengo personalmente
sia un passaggio che se ragazzi
riusciamo a farlo diventare qualcosa di
più grande
magari su scala anche del mercato potrà
dare delle soddisfazioni ha molto da
molti quotidiani
siamo verso la fine c a creare dietro
qui c'è un video
questo è un flowers e questo è il video
che racconta lo sbocciare di un fiore
molto particolare e assume questa
meravigliosa forma in un tempo diciamo
ragionevolmente breve tanto da farci un
time lapse e quindi gabriele ha preso
quel film ha fatto il time lapse l'ha
ridotto in disegni del perimetro ha
messo quei disegni dei perimetri che
crescono uno sopra l'altro è affatto
questo questo è l'unione dello spazio e
del tempo dello sbocciare di un fiore lo
straordinario o quotidiano secondo il
quotidiano perché per esempio non è
fatto di plastica è fatto di ceramica
perché abbiamo imparato a lavorare anche
la ceramica è con noi in italia devo
dire ci sono delle straordinarie realtà
che lavorano la ceramica e tre anni fa
facevano queste casette e adesso fanno
case che sono le più alte del mondo con
la stampante alte alta 12 metri che si
candida a fare moduli da portare nei
paesi del sud del mondo a bassissimo
costo e così arriviamo al parallelo
dello straordinario e quotidiano giulia
avevo un sogno lei in carrozzina da
quando molto piccola di mangiare da sola
e così ci ha chiesto un bacetto si
chiama dandy che costasse poco da poter
osare e usare quando voleva in realtà
lei lo sta muovendo già con un joystick
modificato sulla tua mano sua mano ci
sarebbero tante cose a dire
e qui la stampa 3d e sat ancillare ci ha
consentito di usare dei motori non
perfettissimi stampando pezzi le scocche
e karim si laurea la settimana prossima
con giulia che avrà il suo braccio e poi
mi fa piacere dire questa cosa perché
questo secondo te straordinario perché
sembra non avere a che fare con la
materia ma se vuoi quadrate quella lì
finite sul sito del nostro laboratorio e
trovate tutti i file stl dei pezzi che
vi ho mostrato e anche molti di più e
non importa se non avete una stampante
venite qui a design avete i fab lab
vicino a casa e se qualcuno lo volete
stampare stasera lo potete fare perché
se potete sognarlo parafrasando un
grandissimo potete stamparlo e allora
bisogna essere belli e coraggiosi e dire
con forza il messaggio che vi lascio
questa è tanta roba è tanta roba è tanta
roba
e secondo me attiene a qualcosa che per
me è affidare dare opportunità a chi
lavora con me quotidianamente che è
rivoluzionaria e la rivoluzione fare e
riprendersi il fare che abbiamo un po
perduto questo può cambiare tutto nella
società
credetemi il secondo messaggio che vi
lascio ovviamente qui siamo tutti noi
alla maker faire dove siamo andati a
condividere con bambini famiglie 110
mila persone in tre giorni
queste cose che abbiamo pensato non
dimentichiamo mai ma proprio mai
perché fare è di tutti come dico io
proprio di tutti non c'è verso fare o
non fare non esiste provare a gaza
[Applauso]